latest jobs report is fueling more fears
at a big interest rate hike is likely as
a Federal Reserve tries to aggressively
fight inflation the labor department
said Friday U.S businesses added 263
thousand jobs last month the nation's
unemployment rate dropped from 3.7
percent in August to three and a half
percent last month that matches the
lowest level in the last half century
but the jobs report sent stocks tumbling
Friday the Dow lost more than 2 percent
the s p slid nearly three percent and
the NASDAQ fell almost four percent Jill
Schlessinger has the breakdown Jill good
morning what can you tell us the
September jobs report one was was it
unexpected was it a surprise and what
does it mean for the overall U.S economy
the report itself came in pretty much as
expected we thought analysts said about
250 000 jobs they weren't so sure about
the unemployment rate it moves a lot
based on the size of the labor force but
I think there's something really
important about this report it does show
that job growth is decelerating and that
is not a red flashing signal that a
recession is coming but we know that job
creation last year was averaging more
than a half a million jobs a month this
year we're at four hundred thousand or
so a month and now we're 263 so you can
see slowly kind of coming down now that
said there are some warning signs I
would call them little yellow flashing
signs about what's going on in the jobs
Market not the full red stop sign yet
but we may be getting which means by the
way with all of this that workers who
had leverage quite a bit of Leverage for
quite a while may have less now right
but I mean it's really something
interesting about that slowdown because
we had another report earlier in the
week and it's through August and it's
about job openings job openings fell by
1.1 million in August from July that is
the biggest single month since the
pandemic so you're right in some
respects workers are seeing a little bit
of a shift depends on your industry
depends on your sector but think about
it this way there's still 1.7 workers
for every open job so it's still a tight
labor market and a lot of Industries
can't find workers but if you're in a
consolidating industry or you work for a
company that's going through a hard time
don't be surprised we've heard about big
layoffs or freezing of hiring at Amazon
and Walmart and the like and those are
large employers Michelle mentioned the
overall economy there's still a couple
meetings for the Federal Reserve and
it's the one thing people also want to
know right now interest rates as we've
seen them go up what are we going to see
the rest of the year here we've got two
meetings one in November one in December
I think this report along with next
week's inflation report are going to
keep the FED on track I think we'll get
another 0.75 percent increase in
November maybe a half a point in
December but it is predicated on the
data that's what Jerome Powell the Fed
chair has always said if inflation
doesn't come down we are going to keep
pushing the break remember here's the
critical issue the fed's got two jobs
they want an economy that's strong
enough to have a labor market that's
robust but they've got to control prices
and right now they're failing to control
prices inflation is still accelerating
in many sectors if the recession hits
what can people do to prepare well I
think that there's when when you think
about all the different things that
could go wrong in your life what can you
can take control of I think a lot of
people have spent down a lot of their
savings from the covid era I think
rebuilding your emergency Reserve fund
you want 6 to 12 months of your living
expenses in a safe place I know that's
hard if you're retired I would go one to
two years you want to try to pay down
credit card debt or other high interest
loans and I would be clear if I'm a
worker again we talked about leverage I
think you really have to be careful not
to just move into a new job for money
and the reason is that often if you just
go for say 50 cents more an hour when a
downturn occurs often the last person
into an organization is the first one
out so just be careful lose the security
and the market get get your act together
please I can't handle that sorry I know
you can't you put it so simply just get
your act together thank you very much